foreign
Tomatoes binge guide question for you
who knew that one of our favorite
Survivor and Amazing Race contestants
would go on to become the creator of one
of the best TV shows ever on TV but that
is exactly what has happened with the
hit HBO series The White Lotus it is
created written and directed by Mike
White who has previously written films
like School of Rock and co-created
series like enlightened not to mention
is aforementioned forays into reality
competition shows the White Lotus is a
social satire looking at the dysfunction
of various guests and employees of the
fictional White Lotus Resort chain while
Things become increasingly mysterious
intense as their exploits are unraveled
also that music really UPS anxiety now I
was originally supposed to be a six-part
limited event but went on to become the
most awarded series at the 74th Prime
Time Emmys winning 10 Awards in total
and with that kind of success naturally
it was renewed as an anthology series
instead one that will tell the story of
a different group of Travelers that and
other White Lotus properties after
checking out Hawaii and Sicily in
seasons 1 and 2 respectively
hi
I saw you guys on the boat and on the
plane
where are you from
New York
what neighborhood on East Village but
I'm letting go of my place I'm going to
move into Shane's place my husband's my
husband's name is Shane where'd you meet
him three friends
not Raya
Raya no
third season has been green lit but it's
gonna be a while so we have confirmed
the stay of five other shows that you
might enjoy as well so throw your
luggage down and let's go for a swim
metaphorically of course on this week's
binge guide starting with our brand new
pick the resort now this dark comedy
mystery series premiered on peacock in
July of 2022 and wasted no time becoming
a hit with critics and not only will
White Lotus fans love it because the
word Resort is literally in the title
but also because it's filled with plenty
of mystery too the show Stars William
Jackson Harper and Kristen milioti is a
couple whose 10th anniversary trip to
the Caribbean turned out to be a bit
more than Sun Tans and Mai Tais do they
have my ties in the Caribbean anyway as
they become involved in one of the
yucatan's most bizarre unsolved
disappearance cases from 15 years prior
no big deal what a vacation now the
mystery involves a once in a century
hurricane two missing people and a
murder which are all connected and lead
to the unraveling of some big life
questions for this couple the series was
created by Andy Sierra who also wrote
the peacock miniseries Angeline and
previously wrote the film Palm Springs
the latter of which also Stars Kristen
miliotti now it seems a certified fresh
first season has been a hit with critics
mostly due to the cast which along with
miliotti and Jackson Harper includes
people like Nick Offerman Skyler jasando
Nina bloomgarden and Luis Guzman love
him top RT critic Brian talarico from
the playlist said that the resort quote
holds itself together through its more
ridiculous flights of narrative fancy
because of the commitment of its cast
while the overall critics consensus says
that quote its likable cast and jaunty
tone make for a compulsively watchable
vacation so if you want a quick couch
vacation for your binging this might be
the resort for you coming in at under
five hours for all eight episodes of
season one and don't forget your
sunscreen here's what I know it belonged
to Sam Lawford who was the 22 year old
college kid from San Diego and on
December 24th 2007 him and his mom and
his dad and his girlfriend went to this
resort called the Oceana Vista now on
Christmas night right following night
Sam goes to bed everything's normal
everything's fine the morning after
December 26 2007. he's gone
he completely disappeared God no no no
nothing gone gone now later that day
just other guest from The Resort Violet
Thompson was also reported missing but
they didn't know each other and there
wasn't a single piece of evidence
connecting them checking in with our
certified fresh pick this week is the
night manager now this six part
mini-series is based on the 1993 novel
the same name by John lay coray known
for other successful adaptations like
Tinker Taylor Soldier Spy now in the
night manager Tom Hiddleston stars as a
former British soldier turned night
manager at a hotel in Cairo he's
recruited a spy on and eventually joins
the inner circle of an international
businessman played by Hugh Laurie who's
believed to be a dangerous arms dealer
Tom and Hewer joined by others like
Olivia Coleman Elizabeth to Becky and
Tom Hollander to round out the cast the
latter Witch is also in White Lotus
season 2 and his appearance paired with
the show's many exotic locations is why
we think White Lotus fans will be happy
bingers with this one after a couple
failed attempts to turn the book into a
movie over the past two decades the
story finally found its place as a
six-part series and that seemed to be
the right move for the certified fresh
night manager along with packing in the
star power and having a script written
by series Creator David Farr now the
critics consensus on this one says that
the show's quote smart writing and
riveting story are elevated all the more
by captivating performances from the two
leads a second season was reportedly
considered for this one but never
materialized so about six hours of your
time is all you'll need to get through
it all and I mean you could pretty much
binge a series in just one sitting but
don't take my word for it you know your
own bodies
face
it's
fine
so what do you want I'd like to to go
back to the restaurant that's all right
that's not what I meant
what do you want
from the world
I don't know I'm gonna plan I'm taking
some time out I believe you
you never relax in your life
if you say so
locking things up as our throwback pick
this week is the classic series The
Prisoner now this 1967 British show only
produced One season but it's still
parodied copied and talked about to this
day it was created by and stars Patrick
Lagoon and follows a secret British
intelligence agent who resigns and is
then abducted now he's taken to an
idyllic Coastal Village it is basically
a really weird prison where everyone is
known by numbers instead of names and
while his captors are looking for
information he's just looking for a way
out what's cool about the prisoner is
that it mixes sci-fi with psychological
drama allegory and spy fiction giving us
White Lotus fans many of the things that
we yearn for in a series the show is
sold as a thriller similar to past
projects from Magoon but it's genre
spanning elements and 1960s
counterculture themes ultimately helped
give it the cult following that it has
today the consensus from critics is that
the prisoner is quote sharply
intelligent visually striking and
bracingly blink while remaining a
political metaphor for the ages and
further adding to that sentiment is top
RT critic Keith Phipps from AV club who
said quote more than 30 years old and
still one of the strangest and best
shows in television history the
prisoners remained more heard about than
seen well Keith that's why we're here a
six-part mini-series remake came along
in 2009 with Jim Caviezel starring and a
rather rotten score on the Tomato Meter
so it's a 1967 version You're Gonna Want
and it's 17 episode season which you can
binge in just over 14 hours but hey
don't be a prisoner to the time there is
no rush
we'll be open in a minute what's the
name of this place you're new here
aren't you where do you want breakfast
where is this The Village yes our safe
coffee's ready where's the police
station there isn't one can I use your
phone oh we haven't got one where can I
make a call well there's a firm box
around the corner
[Music]
now our under the radar pick this week
is the mini-series and then there were
none this is an adaptation of the
best-selling Agatha Christie crime novel
from 1939. it aired on the BBC and may
be familiar to those across the pond but
it's had less play here in the states
except for Acorn TV subscribers ICU
acornies is that what you guys call
yourselves this three-part series
follows 10 strangers who are invited to
a remote Mansion based off Britain's
Devin coast once at their destination
the guests realized that they were cut
off from the rest of the outside world
and that something mysterious awaits
them now this group includes an unstable
doctor and irresponsible Playboy and
anxious businessman and a governess with
a secret and once people start turning
them dead it becomes clear that there is
a killer in the group and then there
were none features an impressive
ensemble cast with names like Sam Neal
and Miranda Richardson and a bunch of
others that you would most definitely
recognize from great past works and
together they pull off with the critics
consensus calls quote Dark Yet dashingly
executed offering a brazingly
misanthropic look at Human Nature taking
that a step further is top RT critic
John Doyle from Globe and Mail who
called it quote a portrait of society
coolly and objectively done it might be
an old Christy novel but it is socially
realistic and socially critical this
kicked off a series of Christy
adaptations written by Sarah Phelps for
the BBC that also includes the Pale
Horse and the ABC murders but for fans
of White Lotus this three-part series is
the one that you're gonna want right now
and after you binge it in just three
hours you can walk around telling
everyone that you just mentioned a whole
show in one day they'll be impressed
people do not just die out of nowhere
for no reason they die because something
was done to them by someone
how about I do it
I'm not being searched like some grubby
criminal then what if the general goes
with him
he's an honorable man fine
but while you're at it you might want to
search judge wargrave's case as well and
finding our editors picked this week is
the popular ABC series Lost now
appealing to White Lotus fans with this
beautiful island location and a mystery
to solve this series follows the
survivors of a commercial airplane that
crashes on a strange and unknown Island
somewhere in the South Pacific lost
which also has sci-fi and Supernatural
elements mixed in was created by JJ
Abrams Jeffrey Lieber and Damon Lindelof
who together wrote the pilot episode and
had JJ directed and leading a large
ensemble cast was Matthew Fox who played
Jack but because of that huge cast not
to mention the expense of filming on
location in Oahu this was one of the
most expensive shows on TV there was a
14 million dollar price tag on the
two-part pilot episode alone the most
expensive in ABC's history at the time
turns out the cost was worth it though
with the first season averaging 16
million viewers per episode and among
the many accolades earned over the six
fresh seasons of Lost was two of the big
ones an Emmy for Outstanding Drama and a
sag award for outstanding ensemble in a
drama now critics praised it for its
character-driven plot and the depths of
its Castaways calling it quote one of
TV's most unique undertakings plus the
show's cult-like fan base fans worldwide
and is still going strong known to
gather at conventions and naturally
online now loss put out 121 episodes
during its run and while the series
finale was very polarizing among fans
and critics it's still considered by
many in both of those groups to be among
the greatest shows of all time and it'll
only take you about 88 hours to binge
just don't get lost while you're doing
it please
shot you okay I feel like I've got a
cinder block on my chest but I'll
survive I'm sorry you got shot I didn't
intend for that to happen really
does it seem like you're about to shoot
me yourself
what good would you be to meet Dad
I feel much more comfortable now thanks
all right my friends that's it hopefully
we have helped you fill out your binging
to-do list for the next couple weeks and
by the way if you're looking to find
more great shows for binging purposes be
sure to grab a copy of our book ultimate
binge guide it is full of Specialists it
features some of the best shows of all
time as always don't forget to find us
again for more selections based on the
shows and movies that you love it is all
right here on Rotten Tomatoes binge
guide and I'll see you guys later peeps
[Music]
thank you